1ST ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
3..2..1... Action!
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
Black Widow is something that
the Marvel Universe has
never experienced before.
The action in this film is real.
You have these huge armored vehicles going
through these iconic streets in Budapest.
Budapest itself is so important to who
Natasha really is and what drives her,
and she finds this
family from her past there.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
So we're gonna talk like grown-ups?
YELENA BELOVA
Is that what we are?
FLORENCE PUGH
Within like two days of knowing Scarlett,
I was just ramming
her into a door frame.
All the fighting in this film is so
emotional and about not knowing
how to say what you feel.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
It's good to see you too, sis.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
There's some of the most intense fights
that we've had in the MCU.
DAVID HARBOUR
There's this big fight scene in this
enormous prison.
There were 400 extras.
RACHEL WEISZ
It sort of doesn't feel like a movie.
It feels real.
CATE SHORTLAND
I wanted to create something really
visceral and fun, but to
talk about Natasha as a human being.
To let audiences see a side of her
that they had never seen before.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
I've spent a decade of time with
this character,
and she's finally able
to write her own story.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
I'm done running from my past.